so let's talk about what's happening
around cremenchuk i mean
they say it was an arms depot obviously
that was a shopping center that was
damaged what kind of message are we
drawing from this attacker well what
other russians say we have to take with
a pinch of salt all the time we've got
to try and analyze what we see face
value a brutal attack carnage wreaked on
the ground and actually it wasn't just
there there have been attacks all over
the country um the real question here is
why was it to send a message to g7 was
it a message to try to send a message to
the president zelinski or the wider
world or actually was it genuinely
military targets um putin has to be
concerned at the flow of weapons coming
in from the west because some of the
modern weapons have the real potential
of turning the tide of this battle so
there's no doubt that putin will be
trying to target those lines of
communication rail hubs etc and also
ammunition factories and whilst he
claims that the ammunition factory uh
was nearby this target in in in the
supermarket the reality is he missed the
target and it does appear that russians
are missing more targets than they're
hitting at the moment the concern is the
law of armed conflict which goes back
four thousand years um means that every
reasonable attempt should be made to
avoid um civilian casualties and
infrastructure
back 100 years ago this sort of attack
might have been just considered
collateral damage we used to precision
weapons in the 21st century this appears
to be entirely avoidable and obviously
we've got coming later the opening of
that nato conference in madrid i mean
what are we taking from the fact that
nato have massively increased the troops
of ready deployment um in the coming
weeks yeah the part the irony here is
you won the clock back a few weeks nato
was trying desperately not to get
involved into the conflict itself now
we're seeing nato stepping up efforts to
increase its numbers uh et cetera the
challenge here is is putin's attack
purely tactical take the donbass land
bridge crimea
war is over shortly or his language
starts to about peter the great he
starts talking about some of the former
warsaw pact countries actually being
part of the family of russia and clearly
an expansionist agenda to restore
russian greatness the challenge with
that is we look at the um former uh
baltic states listening latvia and
estonia they're now part of nato and
therefore nato has to be prepared it
can't wait for the attack to happen and
that's why we're seeing forty thousand
high readiness troops now becoming three
hundred thousand high readiness troops
just in preparation for the worst and we
can see that uh russian exclude their
kaliningrad surrounded by those nato
countries now let's speak a little bit
about what we heard from the head of the
new head of the british army um general
patrick sanders talking about 1937. just
give us a little history lesson as to
what he's talking about in 1937. yeah
well 1937 of course we were less than
two decades after the end of the first
world war and um nazi forces have just
entered the rhineland but hitler had
said i've got no ambitions beyond this
in anywhere in europe at the time uh the
prime minister neville chamberlain and
the british public had no appetite for
war whatsoever they'd recovered from
world war one no appetite a war and
therefore the leadership was trying to
appease uh hitler at the time two years
later of course we were dragged into a
war which were singularly unprepared for
and it took a couple of years before we
were able to get ourselves properly
prepared and then liberate europe why
their analogies to today well there are
several nations particularly in europe
who are have a challenge between
domestic politics and international the
high fuel prices the high inflation
prices many of them would like to see
this war in ukraine end come to some
sort of conclusion quickly
and appease putin the problem is this is
putin's war he's the guy and if we're
going to avoid history repeating itself
the west has to be prepared and have a
credible deterrent and that's why you're
seeing a lot of the forces lost the
rhetoric about 1937 the decision point
best to plan for the worst and hope for
the best